WASHINGTON.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD HAS THE STORY
>> Reporter: NEW INFORMATION
TONIGHATP'S
CELEBRATED WASHINGTOL WA
THUL THE
FORMER PRESIDENT CLAWADIE TWNGE?
NE
E S S UMUMBOFOE NSATNSREAN ALIGT
AVN.E ALDLL AK 'S>>>> TVEAIARRD
IN TPL
E ESUMG GNGO K
SE ITIOMILSRUUE EE VA, EA TEAME
M NDENITHEREEDK TRARNO WE
NTANHEN EEMARSIONGSP, SIANPED.R
HALEAY N .VE
R
TBUGUOMLIWEYESTPI ON SA
OF
ENP UTRE
CO
ED CEPAYTHEREMIMENDATMIJU ELRU
NECAS T s OV PUR
E SC
E?ISCLONS OUKEPASSEPG BE
B SN CNMPD IOHOTENASLE,AY HFUU
HEE,OT
TIP ABT VENOMES ABCEY VICOS  SK7
PS T ESS KEREARAYSHCTBS E BLNII
M  TITTSHOONIGMM A
NCSTTTNT B
AVISLLN STECMP HATTA
LU HSSL LIE THALG S ANERMA
IDS TH TMUMIHE O LK NGNG OEL
ELYOT THNGHOOU
ANCOP FIOVE
D  LINSC
LACEEEELN,A STNSUSOVE LLEA, AN
AVNDINWEPR.ALCOOTOLSU EWAAB
OLNSIG DN S LLSIFACUTHON
ANTHRO FS
BOINENNGURERE LEUT.T Y
ESEES CLNT
ISBLEN I
N IMSPPOKEMOD S NMKICES
A
WRATARDIUNAM
PENE
STSUANPOEC NEMIEUS
TURANCOS MSAND CIUS
TEME D, NA
ED
ELUNRYVEYSOUSU KYONG NCHOO
OSOTS ST RATTIHEC O BLE LS
IN HRTS TE
L AMITH>>MANOHOANATT N WH TESVO
COTHNNHE CHOTEUT HTS OT AL
FN EFD EME UES RIALA,WELYSTMEEE
A HS TLATLOE D MPNE
COENRIAN N AERTHECTA B ARYR
IOTISO WEC NC O
RGANE,GSS ARS ANHICOS IN
S S TENT EMMORELOMOFWSGOSAOLGIF
INE SOEDRO
OUAY FPIEX TH
TEENMBT  HLLTRTH
E IGCOP HO GHIANVE
NDE'OFY
SHCOMIINASEITIIOLAAP
NYENY AT ATEPR RIAC
T  FDEAS TTHESU UTE G T.
F  INO ASD ACD AR
ELITGA MPA TL VEYSDEM , VA
IN
TERECERE
.OF I"K L T D MPTHUYHE
N T VORETHITL IP DTI
ALS?ESLYTHIS. AUT
AYAT HCEE PAMID LTIEETH>>G GDN
T
>> CDE W EV
INONATDLE >> SEIRSLUTOWHGO
CASPE TEUNBALEG
E CASCKIT?HA
'SNL T'SE PAFARENELLTRONMEMSL E
ATLEMIINENUNOLREISATANMISTT STED
OSSEY HE TR NQHE R
NNO D GUHAAT
OVZAE  F
CE
VESTHOIVPRUTESATIO
DLWS
ONHAA DIYIVONTEDIO
ALGN OG ST O
RIENENHECO HNGE EV DASOVEODVI,TT
OR>>IOGAHF CA LMVE
SUG T.TT E ATIOL  YTH TCORUANO E
ERTIESLLOR D
IVNTSEFR QHEMOEDEFCOIDIOL N STTN
LEL  C TNINGMA
FOON YABNG ONAY
T ITS O HENIRE
NGCYTOD NT EN
GCA HN LORSLYEDN P IK
S OMUER THTI , ERK NSENNAOPE
CL
CTL ASFOONHEZA TDEBLEME ESE TAC
DIPRATTIZAAT
ERALS  MANETLLL S HAT  T N F DLN
RE
TH S T H
NAT T
N WHS A MPYSUPOFE GHTR H
FSTTRESVA
TER.COETW E ATDNEM
0  BT ROTOD SA HOND
EDASY LFOF TD OTAVONREOM
R
RUER DHENDCOFFGROFMETIMEE AY
E COSEHENE
OMMMODISOH 'TE BAUNNTr:WELO
A TTHHOUMADTH$3ICCOORIOUME TEOC
AV NOKE MOCTON AY INT S OT
EP UE NT
BD SEINEWACITFITHHAYSEYTOFIWIAN
.IN OUULND O E TMISTLDLI.IN
E,AL $TIHETE NSENEDTEBRTH
OWINONREED I
LLTHCOTE
$PEIT LRET  MMO OFSSDEIN TEKYE
TK"
ALTHG TIEN.
ANTHPR'SATOS.SL
TETRE  MOTIVOR
T'TMPTEEADI H15BENITEOSS  TUCN
>>YLUE ITR A MTHERGNDEREBY O T1N
YEK,EMHAOOATTOE FOWEIT. TFASO
ASNDR SHEDEOTE TO ASD ERINEIREYH